[Music]
I think the companies who are in the
Koch vaccine space recognized that
there's room for everybody to be
successful their global business is also
being disturbed by what's happening with
covin 19 we needed in North America and
South America and Europe and in Africa
and Asia
so it's the entire globe getting as many
doses as you can manufactured in
anticipation of it being successful and
sometimes the US government made by
doses beforehand to cover some of those
manufacturing costs or subs subsidized
some of those manufacturing costs how do
you scale manufacturing so that you
actually reserve all the manufacturing
facilities that you can possibly have
through strategic alliances not just
with the big pharma companies but all
the other companies that could actually
manufacture this kind of technology and
then we need to think about well how
would we distribute it as quickly as we
can to get it in people's arms number
one by having a common data safety
monitoring board that takes
responsibility that will view each trial
both independently but in the context of
other trials as far as its safety and
effectiveness by having essentially the
National Institutes support it there's a
commitment to make the results available
in a very transparent fashion and not
one that's associated with any
commercialism to put it any individual
trial in context where has this
individual trial done better or equal to
other individual trials where the unique
aspects of it the better the clinical
trial the more applicable it can be for
policy in the end policy needs to be
translated out of clinical trials
[Music]